the dust is barely settled on Avengers
infinity war in Avengers endgame but
fans of the popular superhero franchise
have been clamoring for more from the
bosses at marvel studios we don't yet
know what adventures 5 could look like
but that won't keep us from speculating
in terms of the cast there are a few
characters we can safely say won't be
returning to the Avengers Iron Man is
definitely out of the mix considering
that he sacrificed himself at the end of
endgame to save the universe from Thanos
[Music]
Black Widow also set a heartbreaking
goodbye when she threw herself off a
cliff to ensure that Hawkeye would get
his hands on the soul stone
Captain America won't be making an
appearance either as he's lived out his
life with Peggy Carter in the past and
is now a senior citizen the only member
of the original big three that could
still play a role as Chris Hemsworth's
Thor who is part of the base for plans
with that fourth solo film Thor love and
thunder due out in 2021 however that
flick is set to see him handover the
mantle of Thor to Jane Foster who will
appear as the first female Thor and
could form part of a new Avengers team
so who does that leave well we know that
Captain Marvel is thought to be leading
the franchise from here on out there's
also spider-man although his future role
in the MCU is still very much uncertain
after his third solo film we also have
Doctor Strange black panther Valkyrie
war machine the Winter Soldier and the
Falcon doom cap gifted a shield at the
conclusion of endgame many of these
characters already have new movies or
series in the works due for release in
phase four so it seems pretty inevitable
that they'll appear in a team-up movie
of course it's quite possible that a
totally new iteration of the Avengers
will make its debut in phase four teams
from the comics such as the New Avengers
Young Avengers and even the West Coast
Avengers might soon see some of their
members introduced on the big screen or
in Disney Plus series with Marvel
Studios recent emphasis on diversity The
Young Avengers are probably the best
option for the film's going forward the
group includes superheroes such as
Wiccan who is gay and dates his teammate
Oakland and black bisexual hero prodigy
heroes such as these could help bring
the MCU into the 21st century and be a
bit more representative of today's
society than the franchise has been in
the past
a key member of the Young Avengers is
Kate bishop the second character to take
on the mantle of Hawkeye
she's already confirmed to be included
in phase 4 as she's set to have a role
in the Hawkeye Disney Plus series Marvel
President Kevin Feige has already
confirmed that many of the characters
introduced in those Disney Plus series
will have roles to play in the film's
going forward to what extent we don't
know yet but Marvel does certainly look
to be setting up the Young Avengers to
take the center stage at some point in
the future the casting call for the
Disney plus series she-hulk has been
revealing with the independent reporting
that its final line stated that whoever
lands the role of Jennifer Walters will
eventually be a quote future member of
the Avengers that would make she-hulk
the first character set to be introduced
on Disney Plus that the studio has
actually confirmed will play a major
role in the MCU films in the future
Feige had previously talked about
she-hulk crossing over to the big screen
at some point but the casting call is
the first confirmation that she will
actually be an Avenger one day the
studio is looking for a woman between
the ages of 26 and 34 with no preference
as to a racial background currently
there has been no casting announcement
so presumably the search for the newest
member of the Avengers is still on
another major addition to the MCU could
come in the form of the x-men while
their introduction into the MCU is
previously impossible Disney's
acquisition of Fox Studios has made it
inevitable we'll figure everything out
together just come back to me remember
you said you'd always come back to me
come back to me fans have been clamoring
for this ever since the deal and there's
even a compelling theory or two about
how the mutants could materialize in the
universe one has to do with the upcoming
Disney Plus Series Wan division which
will lead directly into the events of
the feature film Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and which will see
the scarlet witch's reality-warping
powers finally start to come into play
one does incursions into other realities
within the multiverse could provide a
door through which the x-men could
arrive in the MCU fully formed another
concerns the reality stone which was
last seen being transported safely back
to 2013 Asgard by Captain America the
stone could theoretically allow a
powerful enough user to breach
interdimensional barriers without the
use of magic but all of this is of
course speculation at the moment
it certainly seems likely that the x-men
will make their first MCU appearance at
some points in phase four but it remains
to be seen whether any of their number
will be pressed into service as a member
of the Avengers what is certain is that
Marvel is taking some time to allow
legacy characters to breathe while
introducing new ones into the MCU given
that this is the first time no Avengers
film was announced in an entire phase
with many established heroes saying
their goodbyes at the end of endgame the
universe needs to bulk up the hero bank
before they're able to take on another
major villain that needs to be faced as
a collective Feige has said that for him
endgame was an ending and while he
hasn't closed the door on the
possibility of more Avengers films at a
later date he wants the studio for now
to be focused on telling new stories
given the lineup for phase 4 and the
next few years it seems clear that
they're trying to do just that before
considering another major crossover film
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]